each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay thank you for coming and
for people who are watching
online uh we are very happy to have with
us ABI Raa abik is actually an associate
professor sorry should come yeah uh
uh uh abik is a associate professor at
the National University of Singapore and
he earned his PhD from uh Stony Brook
he's actually been there for almost 10
years now uh he has very diverse
interests ranging from embedded systems
to software testing and Analysis
symbolic execution Etc so he's actually
going to talk about some of his work
today okay thank you
okay so should I begin okay okay so uh
this talk will be on the rle of symbolic
execution in software testing uh
debugging and repair and essentially
I'll even though I will talk about uh
some specific techniques uh I'll try to
go into the role that symbolic execution
is playing in each of these techniques
okay so of course uh first of all I must
uh mention that the growth of symbolic
execution uh that we have seen in the
software engineering community in uh use
in different software processes this is
driven a lot by the uh smt solver
technology maturity okay so without the
growth in smt solver technology many of
these techniques would not be
possible and uh the purpose of this talk
is really to see whether uh this can be
used symbolic uh execution can be used
in newer ways in software engineering so
of course the there is a uh process
Centric view that is whether uh symbolic
execution can be used Beyond uh testing
and verification where it has
conventionally been used so for example
I'll try to talk about how uh it has
been used in uh debugging and repair
where conventionally symbolic techniques
were not used but also I think there is
a conceptual View and uh that is
symbolic execution is quite a bit has
been used for guiding search in a uh
large search space
and whether one can go Beyond and try to
use symbolic techniques for inferring uh
intended behavior and really what is the
uh secret recipe that makes symbolic
execution drive both of these uh roles
that is guiding the search in a huge
search space as well as inferring the
intended behavior of programs because of
course as you might imagine if you can
uh infer the intended behavior of a
program then debugging activities like
debugging become much more Tractive
able so uh really speaking the the
perspective uh that we are taking for uh
symbolic execution in this talk is that
conventionally it has been used uh quite
a bit uh well when I say conventionally
it is conventionally now but some time
back it was not so conventional in uh
test generation model checking and so on
where it is exploiting the similarities
in the SE space and also at the same
time it can use symbolic execution can
be used as some sort of a psychiatrist
trying to uncover what went wrong and uh
this is really the role that is being uh
played by symbolic execution when we use
them in debugging summarization
semantics extraction program repair and
so on
okay so uh when I uh talk about
debugging in this uh talk I should uh
very uh clear clearly clarify the
difference between uh the bug hunting
and debugging of course in uh uh in many
of the papers which use model checking
for finding bugs uh this is also
mentioned as debugging but that is
really bug hunting where you have a
certain property in mind and a program
and you produce a counter example and
the counter example essentially says
that okay you know under these uh under
these uh input conditions this property
is violated whereas what we are
mentioning here as debugging is that
there is a certain input there is a
certain output and we act actually
trying to find out what went wrong in
this particular test case so this is
really the debugging problem that we are
looking at so here uh certain uh
property uh is not given to us what is
the property that was violated this is
what we are trying to find but on the
other hand we have a failing Trace okay
so this is the debugging problem that we
are looking at yeah and you do you want
the property or the the the uh the the
uh the part of the code
that yeah we want the part of the code
which is the likely uh suspect for the
violation of the expected output and
then so then property is is is much more
General than the piece of theod that's
right that's right so we really won't be
infering the properties in in debugging
that's right yeah
so I think uh these are the things that
uh I believe I can skip so there's the
uh of course you have uh symbolic uh uh
execution uh you just replace the input
with a certain Theta and then you have
the concrete output as well as the
symbolic output so the uh symbolic
outputs are given in terms of theta and
uh of course the path in symbolic
execution we have quite a bit of uh
usage of path
conditions uh where in this case given
the input uh equal to five coresponding
to each line number that is executed you
can keep track of an assignment store
and a certain uh path condition and the
path condition really captures the set
of all inputs uh which go through this
path okay so at any point of time you
can keep track of the branches that you
are uh going through uh the branch
conditions and for any branch condition
that you are conjoining you can look up
the symbolic store and this is how you
can compute the path condition
automatically okay so in our usage of
symbolic execution we will be having a
fair amount of uh usage of path
conditions and uh the usage of these
path conditions has been uh uh has been
fairly extensively uh popularized in
this directed automated random testing
uh method where you continue the search
for failing inputs and in particular
inputs that go don't go through the same
path so for example the aim here is
really to get uh path coverage so for
each uh each path you capture the path
condition and you negate a little bit of
it so for example if you start with this
uh with this bold uh path you this is
the path condition and you negate a
little bit of it and you get another
path condition and you try to get a
solution for this you negate a little
bit of B more you get another path
condition you get a solution for this
and so on so the aim is really to make
sure that you don't have uh inputs which
go through the same path again and again
and again so this is uh this is uh a
fairly well known at this stage a fairly
wellknown usage of symbolic execution in
testing so uh there is uh when you use
Dynamic symbolic execution uh for
testing in this way there is some sort
of an implicit assumption and the
implicit assumption is that the inputs
that execute a certain path is are
similar okay so if you test one of them
there is no need to test the others okay
so essentially that you we are using
similarity to skip over parts of a large
search space and the dynamic symbolic
execution is essentially a tool which
helps us achieve this goal okay so the
first thing that uh I'll mention today
uh that that is a usage of symbolic
execution again in test generation is
whether one can look at corser grin
Notions of similarity which are useful
for test
generation so uh this is uh the uh uh
slide which shows the different roles
played by symbolic execution in testing
debugging and repair in testing uh
really the uh goal is always that we
don't need to test for similar inputs
and there is the possibility of looking
for similarity Beyond paths that is
probably combining paths into one single
partition of paths in debugging of
course given a failing input we are
trying to find out similar inputs which
pass okay so we will see that one can do
logical comparisons to detect the
deviations between these failing inputs
as well as the similar inputs that pass
and finally in repair uh there is the
question of finding similar inputs which
show the same error and therefore you
can rescue them all and this forms the
search space of all possible
repairs uh and here also symbolic
execution we will see is used to capture
the intended behavior of the program
okay so uh the uh this is how I'll try
to set the stage for the usage of
symbolic execution in testing debugging
as well as repair and at all points of
time try to go back and see what role
symbolic execution is playing in each of
these
techniques so let me start with an
example technique from testing so this
program actually has uh eight paths uh
not surprisingly with the three branches
there are eight paths but we can uh see
that uh they can be partitioned into
just these three partitions based on the
symbolic outputs so if you take the
input output relationship that is
captured the output as a symbolic
expression in in terms of the inputs
then these are the conditions under
which you have different symbolic
outputs that this is the condition under
which the output is two here the output
is X okay the X and Y and Zed are the
inputs and here the output is y so this
is another notion of similarity which
one could use which uh probably goes
beyond the directed automated random
testing and it would be nice if if you
could comp compute these path partitions
automatically of course I'm just
defining these path partitions here I
haven't said how to compute
them so if we could compute these path
partitions automatically this is the
kind of a summary that we will generate
for the program that under these
conditions the output is two under these
conditions the output is X under these
conditions the output is y so
on and it turns out that it is possible
to compute these path partitions
actually automatically uh if you do a
bit of dependency analysis over and
above symbolic execution so instead of
computing the path conditions on the
paths we compute the path conditions
over the so-called uh relevant slices
which are uh which is essentially an
extension of the backward Dynamic
slicing so the dynamic slicing is a
closure of control and data dependences
the dynamic control and data dependences
the data dependencies are just the used
definition chains and the control
dependencies point out to the closest in
closing Branch so over and above these
control and data dependencies which
capture the uh effect of all the
statements which affect the output by
getting executed we also have the
so-called uh potential dependencies
which capture the effect of statements
which affect the output by not getting
executed so for example here I have this
example here this is actually uh
potential dependence
because because because of this Branch
because this Branch got evaluated in a
certain direction this statement did not
get executed and this affected the
output okay so if you also capture the
effect of these statements which did not
get executed and thereby affected the
output and combine it with Dynamic
slicing and you compute the path
conditions over these extensions of
dynamic slicing es you can really try to
uncover the transformation function
underlying the program okay so this is
clearly much beyond the uh the directed
automated random
testing because you compute these
partitions so I will not uh go into the
details of these properties but these
properties are important for the search
to be
complete uh so here we compute these uh
relevant slice conditions that is the
path condition over these relevant
slices uh uh over the different
parts uh and uh the property that we
have is that given a path if an input
satisfies the relevant slice condition
uh if an input T Prime satisfies the
relevant slice condition of T then its
relevant slice condition is the same so
really uh these are the inputs which
compute the same symbolic output so now
the search will proceed exactly as in
directed automated random testing you
start with a random input you go through
its path you compute the relevant slice
over that path you compute the relevant
slice condition over that relevant slice
and this captures a whole group of
inputs who have the same symbolic output
and now you have to modify this relevant
slice condition a little bit so that you
can move into another group of inputs
which have a different symbolic
output so if you took took the straight
line program
translated into bounded model
sh then the relevant size condition is
is like a all
set
that all set I it's an all set with
respect to projection and criteria which
is the output yeah so there enumerate
model the relevant slice condition will
capture all the statements which
actually affect the
output
so I will
essentially
symbol yeah so uh this is all because of
the inherent parallelism in the program
so there might be number of statements
and their uh conditions uh which appear
in the path condition but do not affect
this particular output but but my
question is really suppose you translate
your program directly to logic what does
the relevant slice
uh the answer oh it's all
s uh it's a
dnf ination with respect to a
projection the relevant slice condition
is a Dy is a relatively Dynamic concept
it's not uh it's not a static concept
that given the uh conversion of the
program into the logic I will be able to
get a notion for the relevant slice
condition
so given a path if I start with a random
input given a path for that input it is
a projection of that path and The
Logical representation of that
projection so is it a formula in terms
of the input symbols absolutely okay
absolutely so just like the path
condition it is a formula in terms of
the input symbols so you think of the
path Condition it's like uh many of the
conditions in the path condition are
filtered away and this is because of the
inherent parallelism in the program they
were probably not relevant for the
computation of the
output but you don't know based on a
single based on the single path you
don't know which conditions are
important and which are not right based
on the single path I can know by doing
this dependency calculation over the
path so that actually looks at the
entire procedure the dependency analysis
the dependency analysis we look at the
look at the trace
yes yeah but it seems like much of the
time is not really even the output that
matters
for symbolic execution kinds of problems
it's whether oh I don't know you hit
some sort of a you know buff overun or
which might actually not even affect the
output uh or if you say consume a lot of
memory or if something else kind of some
some sort of a secondary condition that
follows that not captured by these
predicates at all that is true that is
true so here I'm doing the path
exploration and the path partitioning
based on the output so it could be that
the the definition of what you want to
test is not captured in the output you
are just trying to look for crashes and
so on that will not be captured by this
path exploration that's correct but is
there a way to do that so suppose I have
a memory consistency check that goes and
traverses my allocator data structures
and does some yes you think yes is there
a way to do something around that yeah
of course you can actually make it
observable you can Define that as the
output and then you once you do the path
partitioning based on that input output
relationship it will capture the
different
partitionings
absolutely so if you are looking for
specifically a buffer overrun you can
Define certain uh certain output
conditions which capture the buffer
overrun and you can do the path
exploration and the path partitioning
based on those output conditions
absolutely but we did not do that
specifically in this work here when I
say as output these are really the
output variables of the program yeah so
if I think of it this relevant slice
condition is an abstraction of the path
condition absolutely absolutely so it
throws away all the things in the path
condition which are really not relevant
for the production of this output
yeah so there is a technical uh details
here which I'm skipping uh so this we
actually proved that the path
exploration based on these relevant
slice condition will really explore all
the symbolic outputs that means the
there's a completeness in the search
which was relatively difficult to prove
and the reason for this is actually the
property that is shown uh below that in
a path condition if you have a certain
path condition if you negate part of it
okay then you can be sure if you negate
say one one of these uh constraints then
you can be sure that the path condition
of the input that uh contains this
negated
formula this contains this formula as
the prefix okay but in the relevant
slice condition because since it's a
slice actually some of these branches
might disappear when you compute the
relevant slice condition and as a result
we have to do some reordering but this
is a more of a technical details for the
sake of proving the completeness of the
search
uh once you do this the validation is
really as expected uh that these are all
the all the programs and then uh the
relevant slice condition was of course
much much uh smaller than the path
condition and then the paths explored
through the relevant slice condition
these are also much much less because of
course many paths are uh online getting
grouped uh into this uh relevant slice
condition so this is uh one usage that
we looked yes sorry there was there's a
question here does this assume that I
mean I don't know what these programs
are number one number two is that does
this assume you can actually run them in
this model if you will end to
end sorry say that again does this
assume that you can actually run them to
the end in this model and capture
everything that you need to capture
that's right so what are these
programs
so what are these programs uh
uh these are all from the I think the
sir what we call uh the software
infrastructure
repository so I think these are these
are not particularly big programs say
about less than equal to I think most of
them are less than equal to thousand
lines of code yeah so you can basically
explore them for yeah yeah but I I guess
the issue is that even if the program
has say 100 line of code if you just
migrate from one group of paths to
another group of paths you have to make
sure that the search does not diverge
and you will actually compute all the
symbolic outputs compute partitions for
each of the possible symbolic outputs
that is what we showed in the
completeness of the search sorry there's
a question here how would you relate
this to summaries so if you create a
summary for a block basic block could
you uncover some of the related
functionality absolutely so this is
absolutely a summarization procedure
even though we used it for test
generation this is absolutely a
summarization procedure and it could
benefit if the basic block summaries
were available yeah but for the
techniques are different as far as
understood mhm yeah so here I you could
think of that I'm trying to uncover the
transformation function underlying the
program somehow
and as you might imagine there could be
unboundedly many symbolic
outputs unboundedly many symbolic
outputs also not just concrete outputs
but symbolic outputs as a result of
which there could be unboundedly many
path
partitions so definitely I cannot show
that the search in this way will
terminate but if there are finitely many
uh and boundedly many uh uh symbol uh
symbolic out outputs then I will have
exactly that many uh path partitions
yeah and that many test
cases so so are you inlining all the
procedures or are you doing them
compositionally here oh no no no I'm not
inlining it's a interprocedural so these
are the number of parts per procedure I
do you use the summary this is the total
number of paths that were uh uh
explored so when you do dat
if there's a call do you use the summary
of that call or do you inline that call
no that would be the way of improving
the search in this case these are really
the traces you see the I'm working with
traces here I start with a random input
I look at its Trace I do the slicing
over that then I do symbolic execution
over that slice actually the slicing and
the symbolic execution are going hand in
hand that produces a formula I do some
uh operations on the formula negate it
produce another formula and then that
moves on to the next PATH
partition right are inter procedural
faes right and you comput the summary
it's a summary of the entire program not
for a given procedure that's right so if
I composition in that sense uh you could
say it that way but if I actually did
put in the summaries of some of the
lower level procedures then it would be
faster but then of course uh it would be
less accurate because then I'm just
treating the whole summary of the
underlying procedure and what is an
output for you here I mean the programs
have their implicit output yeah the
programs have their output and I'm just
using that output if the Heap is not
considered part of the output this was
one of the questions yeah we could make
the Heap as one of the output we we also
did that yeah that's a good question
yeah
okay okay so maybe I'll move on
okay right uh uh so I'll mention to you
one uh way we have used uh uh symbolic
execution for debugging where
conventionally symbolic execution was
not used and this is in this domain of
regression debugging and here you will
see that the uh role of symbolic
execution is very different uh so uh in
regression debugging the problem is very
simple you have a test input it is given
to an old stable program and a new buggy
program and earlier it used to pass and
it now fails and you want to know why so
here the is uh this is this statement is
a little bit informal but then uh the
Assumption here is that when you try to
go from the old stable programmer to the
new buggy program you probably try to
add some new functionality the intended
purpose of the old functionality is as
before okay so therefore this should not
have failed but now it fails and you
want to know
why
so uh this this would be a a very first
thing one could try because the in the
in debugging literature conventionally
there has been a lot of uh uh lot of uh
usage of Trace comparison that is the
test input is fed into the old stable
program and the new buy program and you
produce paths and whether you could
directly compare the paths of course you
cannot directly compare the paths
because there these are really two
different programs and they might have
completely different algorithms and data
structures and so on so it would really
wouldn't be feasible to directly compare
the paths but the question is whether
you can uh you can generate some sort of
a new input sorry you could generate
some sort of a new input using this uh
Evolution information and then you can
compare the behavior of this new input
with the uh with the buggy input to find
out what went wrong okay so this is what
we are trying to do in the debugging
problem and this is a schematic uh to
give the intuition of the of the
debugging method that uh here you have
the input say these are the partitions
here this is just a schematic these are
the partitions assume that uh all uh
inputs in a bin are similar now what is
similar this is up to us to Define what
is similar and uh in this case say the
red input is the buggy input because of
this error that has been introduced it
has somehow shifted from one partition
to another what we are looking for is
something like this blue input which was
similar in Behavior to the red input but
now is different in Behavior but this
blue input has not changed Its Behavior
at all okay it is the red input which
has changed the behavior because of the
error that was introduced and we are
trying to look for a blue input like
this one which is now different in
Behavior so this is really the uh the
intuition sorry you seem to have a
question it seems like the unstated
Assumption here is that your properties
of Interest are not data dependent they
are sort of symbolic formula dependent
which is to say it's possible to have
exactly the same formula that will in
practice yield very different outcomes
especially when interacting with uh you
know systems you're not capturing like
databases right a traditional example
you have a SQL injection which is the
result of concatenating a bunch of
strings the formula is always the same
it's concatenating string a string B and
so forth yet for some devious inputs it
produces a very different outcome and
you see what I mean mhm so there's a
nature there's the of dependency versus
computation dependency that you're not
talking about here yeah that's correct
so uh I did not state that uh uh exactly
what these partitions mean somehow there
is an unstated assumption here that the
error is visible in the control flow if
these partitions actually captur the
control flow in some way uh we did some
other work where this assumption we can
go past this assumption but I I'm not
presenting that technique today but in
this particular technique that is the
case
yes okay so uh so in this uh first work
that we did uh uh on uh on uh debugging
using symbolic uh uh techniques there's
this test input which is fed into the
old stable program and the new BAGI
program and we do a concrete and
symbolic execution compute the path
conditions of the uh of the test input
in both the programs and then
essentially we will uh compute uh
solutions for this Formula F and not
fpre because these are exactly like the
blue inputs which are similar to The
Buggy input in the old program and
different from the buggy input in the
new
program okay and this gives us an
alternative input and actually there is
really no need for us to do the trace
comparison we can just look at
satisfiable sub formula from this uh F
and not F Prime and that would give us
all of these uh symbolic execution is
actually happening at the level of the
assembly code uh this will give us the
bug report at the assembly level and
then we reverse translate it back to the
source level
okay and uh the reason there is no need
to do any of the trace comparison for uh
the solutions of this this FN not fime
is that of course there can be many many
solutions of these ones and we don't
want to explore all of them but note
that the fime is a path condition which
is a a conjunction like this one so of
course when you uh when you uh
uh when you look at uh look at the
negation of this not F Prime you can
consider all possible deviations of it
so it could deviate off in the first
Branch the second Branch the third
branch and so on so if the path
condition has M constraints you only
really need to look at at most M
equivalence classes and for each of them
each of those deviations you really know
which line would go into the bug report
so uh it is is that particular branch
that will go into the bug report so if
the path condition has M constraints you
really have to look at M of those
formulas check which of them are
satisfiable anyone that is satisfiable
you just put the corresponding branch in
the bug report so this is how the
technique
works so it seems that any branch that
can avoid the error will be reported
right any any branch that you can just
take a different path and avoid the it
will be so you not taking into account
the similarity of the two parts here
right you can just diverge in the first
control location first branch and then
just go off
somewh yeah right so New Path might be
somewhere must might have just the first
Branch as common and the rest is
completely different yeah that that's
actually a a good point uh we had some
other uh strategies for prioritizing
among these ones that are satisfiable
where they are also successful the
inputs that we generate by solving those
deviations whether they are also
successful because those could be also
failing uh inputs and those ones we
don't want to consider in the bug
report
yeah so now if we have this picture we
can also employ this corser grain
similarity that I mentioned to you that
is uh look at these path partitions
instead of paths so we can just use
these relevant slice conditions instead
of the path conditions and the the whole
technique would just uh be used for free
and in which case as you might uh
imagine the uh the results become much
much better in fact of course I'm uh
showing you these are much bigger
programs uh than the ones that we showed
for the test generation I think the Nano
XML JX J toas I don't have the exact
sizes but these are much much bigger
programs and you can see that the uh
size both in terms of the size of the
path conditions and relevant slice
conditions in this case we have the the
time for doing the debugging which is
substantially cut down and also the
lines of code because each line of code
is really coming from each of these
deviations that we record so each line
of code is a branch condition that is
given by each of these deviations so
many of the deviations just get filtered
out because of the
slicing
okay and uh of course many of the other
results that we had uh in the original
uh work on Darwin which was by the way
built on uh bit blaz uh the bit blaz
Tool uh so which we are thankful because
they made the tool available to us much
earlier
uh they are they were also replicated
and since this uh technique is
completely based on semantic analysis
one can use it on different
implementations of the same protocol
also for example different web servers
and so on we also used a different
variation of this method on uh finding
out errors in embedded Linux by
validating it against Linux the busy box
these are exactly the errors that are
reported in the CLE paper they did the
test generation and we did the root
causing of all of these
errors
yes yes so here did you intersect the
relevant path condition with the
diff to only focus on
the no no this is just the relevant
slice condition as produced the root
cause for the regression yeah the
branches that you report do you also
consider whether they are present in the
DI no no no no no actually we don't do
that and that is really the uh one of
the uh one of the observations behind
building technique these uh building
these techniques because the error might
not be in the diff the error might very
well be in the original program itself
but it might not have been manifested
and it is now getting manifested so we
are never doing the intersection with
the
diff right so
uh and finally I show you one uh usage
of the symbolic execution in uh in
program repair and this is something we
have uh actually worked on recently so
here when I say uh program repair uh the
correctness specification is given by a
test Suite so when we repair the program
the purpose is to make sure that it
passes all the test cases in this test
Suite uh and the repair strategy uh I'll
go through the repair strategy in a
minute and the usage of symbolic
execution here is to group together all
of these executions through which a
failing execution could be rescued so in
some sense this is a newer notion of
similarity this result was uh just in I
this
year so let me show you the problem uh
with an example this is a very uh very
simple example this is just a uh uh
simple procedure without any loops and
suppose the error is in line number four
uh where the bias equal to down set we
will like to uh we would like to uh have
this corrected to this bias equal to
upset Plus 100 and suppose these are all
the test cases and two of the test cases
in fact fail so the purpose is to
generate a new uh expression for
bias excuse me so that these test cases
actually
pass so the first step of this method is
the Fault localization here we are using
a statistical fault localization method
which actually uh takes in uh the uh the
program and the test cases and tries to
find a line which uh somehow appears
more in the failing test cases and less
in the passing test cases there are many
many metrics for that we are using one
particular metric that is used by this
tarantula tool and so the what we need
to know for understanding the method is
that suppose this method has pointed you
one particular line in this case line
number four how you can correct that
expression that bias equal to downstep
to bias equal to upsp plus 100
automatically okay so this is what the
repair method is
doing and of course you can try try
doing this uh for one line at a time if
it doesn't work you can try to go to the
next line that is given by the
statistical fault localization method is
there a specification for each of these
examples or is there some non pointer
violation there is no specification
so my only goal is to make sure that the
repaired program passes all the test
cases the specification is
given that's right so for each test we
have the input and the expected output
yeah so the first uh step is to uh go to
this line find the suspect and the
second step is to find out through uh
through symbolic execution what it
should have been say if your aim is to
correct the bias equal to down set so
you just replace bias with X and go on
doing symbolic execution from there so
you are doing concrete execution up to
that particular line which you want to
correct and then subsequently you go on
and do symbolic execution from there
okay so you can see here say I replace
the uh the right hand side with X and
the path condition is true at this point
of time and then you can go on forward
and in this case you develop one
particular path condition x uh greater
than 110 in The Other One X less than
equal
to0 and so on and it turns out that uh
this this one leads to a passing
execution and this one leads to a
failing execution
okay so just to make this uh a bit more
concrete so this is really at this point
of time I put this as a function of all
the variables which are live
okay this is really a function of all
the variables that that are Al and I'm
trying to synthesize a function of this
form which takes in all these variables
that are life and I know the values of
each of these variables because I'm
trying to rescue this particular test
case so if these are the values that
were actually fed by this particular
test case I want to synthesize a
function which satisfies this formula
this was obtained from the path
condition that we got
okay excuse me so uh so corresponding to
each test case we will accumulate each
of these constraints and I'm trying to
find out a particular function f which
satisfi satisfies all these constraints
and we can fix the set of operators that
appear in F this will be done by program
synthesis so there are number of methods
in which you can generate the fixes uh
either you can search over the space of
expressions in this case we will
actually use a program synthesis and
finally the generated fix is of this
form so I can go through this in a a
little bit more details so the first
step is the uh the producing the ranked
bug report where we are using just an
off the shelf statistical fault
localization tool for the symbolic
execution we are trying to group all the
parts which can avoid the error so if
you have this line which you want to fix
you just replace it with a certain
variable X and then you do symbolic
execution with X as the only unknown so
this would be actually fairly scalable
because the symbolic execution is only
this particular
variable okay and
uh the x is nothing but the function
over all the live variables so this is
really the function that you are trying
to synthesize so at some point of time
you can just add this constraint that x
equal to the function of all function
over these concrete values and this
would actually implicitly generate
constraints over this function and this
is the function that you want to
synthesize so this is what we call the
repair
constraint and you get a repair
constraint of this form of course we
don't feed this off to the smt solver
just like that uh we will select some
primitive components that can be used in
this function and this is done through
some sort of a layered search so
initially we can see whether there can
just be these can just be constants
constant function if not maybe
arithmetic operators if not logical
operators if then else and so on sorry
there's a question so there's a set of
benchmarks collected for grammar based
synthesis okay so so the way you
describe that your your application fits
directly into those Point by by P
so I am actually using we are actually
using an extension of the uh program
synthesis method uh based on input
output pairs which have been uh
developed here yeah yes but
buture there's a website where they
collecting this
bench uh I'm actually I'm not aware of
that one so okay I'll find the name
okay so uh but the technique that we are
using this uh synthesis method this is
an extension of the io pair based
synthesis method which has been
developed yeah
yeah so uh so instead of directly
feeding this uh formula off to the smt
solver we are looking uh for a program
that uses a given set of primitive uh
components and the components we are
searching for this component through
some sort of a layered search and of
course the questions are where to place
each component and what are the
parameters for each component so the way
this is done is essentially we Define
the location variables for each
component and then we get constraints on
the location variable so the uh simple
example that I have here this is the the
only component is just a plus and these
are the location variables this is the
location variable of the input to the
program this is the location variable
variable to the output to the program
the location variable for the output of
the plus of the first input of the plus
the second input of the plus and so on
so just this assignment of the location
variables gives me the program and that
gives me the uh expression to
synthesize okay so uh it will uh
generate a constraint system on these
location variables which will be solved
to get an assignment to these location
variables and and that gives me the
program to generate and that also gives
me the expression that is to be
synthesized so actually these are the
subjects that we used again the first
set of subjects are from the sir the
software infrastructure repository that
we use in uh software engineering uh
community and also some others from the
gnu core utils uh uh these are the
utilities like mkdir MK F4 copy and so
on uh and here in the Repair actually
this is really the first work that uses
any kind of semantic analysis for repair
this I can say with confidence uh in the
past there was a lot of work there you
have probably heard of the Gen prog tool
which uh which does repair by using
genetic programming so we also triy to
uh try to look for these uh benchmarks
or uh subject programs against the
genprog tool
and both of these were repaired by the
GP as well as the samfix tool the for
the gnu core utils even though
surprisingly even though our technique
uses symbolic execution it was faster
because the symbolic execution is used
in a fairly scalable fashion with very
few
variables do it matter does it matter
yeah you will see whether it matters or
not okay so these are the uh I think I
will convince you that it does matter
with this uh slide so you can see here
the correctness criteria is given by the
number of test cases okay so uh of
course if I add more and more test cases
my correctness criteria becomes more
stringent right so whatever was a valid
repair earlier may not be a valid repair
anymore so now you can see the the graph
for the repairs produced by this genprog
tool and the repairs that we are
producing which is the blue line so the
repairs that we are producing are much
more stable and the reason is it is
actually based on analysis of the paths
so later on if you add test cases which
go through the paths that were already
tried out earlier then of course the
repair that was valid earlier will
continue to be
valid okay uh so this is not surprising
that ours is much more stable whereas
here you can see the one that is by
genprog this is producing by genetic
programming so effectively it is trying
to get the repaired expression from
somewhere else in the program by moving
it to the
uh to the buggy site and the uh the
repairs that are produced are not valid
as you add more and more test cases and
these test cases were not Cherry Picked
by us these are actually each of these
programs come with a predefined set of
test Suite okay which were produced by
some sort of a coverage criteria so
First We Take 10 of those randomly then
add 10 more randomly 10 more randomly
and so on just to do the experiment in a
proper way yep
yeah but are you PR to over fitting more
so than gen the other way
around uh overfitting uh I'm not sure in
other words the size of the model I mean
you can basically generate a program
that would do perfectly on uh what is it
50 or so 45 or so test cases okay but
that program will be really hideous and
special casing for every one of those
test cases yeah but of course means you
can always repair the program like if if
you knew the test cases then if this
then this if of course we are not doing
that yeah right there would be no way
the technique doesn't know what the test
cases are going to be
fed it cannot possibly know yeah
confusion how was when you're trying to
synthesize the F function yeah you're
not doing it on a single failing test
right you accumulate all the failing
test Abol you Fe it to the synthesiz
absolutely yeah so the repair constraint
actually generates constraints on their
F function for each of the tests and of
course doing it for each of these tests
that that may be a bit cumbersome so
there are some optimizations for doing
that you're saying that if you increase
the set of tests this F becomes
unsatisfied you cannot if you throw in
hundreds of tests then the synthesizer
might not be able to give you yeah what
I said yeah because all of this were
done in a Time
budget yeah so it does not mean that the
repair that was produ says that the
repair that was produced is not a valid
repair does not mean that if more time
was given to the genprog tool it may not
be able to produce that we don't know of
course at some point of time you have to
put a Time budget
yeah right and you uh in fact this is
another slide through which you can see
whether uh it matters uh this is these
are all the different classes of Errors
say uh constant error in constant
arithmetic errors comparison errors
logic errors code missing errors and so
on and this is the comparison between
the genprog tool and this uh semantic
analysis based fixing you can see that
the genprog tool doesn't seem to be
doing so well in some of the categories
where in some some other categories it
is uh sort of okay okay program was used
for analog
circuits repair
synesis very different kind domain mhm
so could you use any these
techniques from PI for
an H I have not explored that
think
okay yeah I I really have not explored
that yeah yeah but uh certainly it would
be feasible I
think uh but uh I have not explored that
at all that's an interesting connection
I have not even thought about that yeah
that's that was like a killer app by
J a 50 proc super computer in his
garage for out
house that's what we were doing
but jrog is is was is tail for software
yeah yeah it is ster for software repair
for program repair but it tries to
borrow repair chunks from the program
itself which is not necessarily the
best yeah essentially maybe I'm
oversimplifying a little bit but
essentially it is trying to copy
expression some from somewhere else in
the program found there
yeah it does these mutation and the
crossover operations of course in the
mutation you can change a little bit but
it becomes very difficult to synthesize
a real fix with those kind of operations
Shu maxat based repair by buok uh did
you look into that uh yeah we we did
look into that so there's the maxat
based uh debugging
right yeah but I guess they did not look
looking to repair that much yeah it's
more more the debugging that is
essentially try in fact in a later uh
manifestation of this work we are trying
to use uh certain variations of maxat
for repair in this case as you saw we
are essentially just fixing one line but
one could probably try to fix together
several lines at the same time lines
that are correlated and whether maxat or
such techniques can be used that a
possibility okay and uh just to very
quickly go through so uh even though
there is just one line fix that we are
generating it's also possible to because
the lines can be fairly complicated you
can synthesize missing code or you can
have if analysis within the fix that you
are generating and uh thereby um have
this uh operations this this other
capability less than all value if so
then two three reports valid and so on
so this is a fairly complicated fix that
is being
generated so just stepping back uh in
terms of the repair of course there are
uh I don't think of it will be uh
completely automated so there is the
issue of building programming
environments and putting the uh human in
the loop and I think in the repair the
program synthesis is uh likely to play a
useful role uh is debugging required
this is a little bit questionable to me
so as the first step of this repair we
put the first the statistical fault
localization which already goes to the
line and then I try to repair that line
uh maybe that is not needed so one could
think of repair methods which does the
testing and repair handin hand and
avoids the statistical fault
localization altogether that means you
through some symbolic execution you try
to generate test cases and as the test
case actually fails you try to repair
these test cases that you found so this
is pro probably an answer to your
question that you mentioned just now one
could find the location to fix via this
symbolic reasoning as well as Max set so
I think there is a possibility we have
been trying this out but this is not
very scalable so there are there are
difficulties with
this and of course there is the issue of
suggestions generating suggestions
instead of repairs we have tried to look
into the usage of this for generating
repairs of Access Control errors and so
on uh which is a different story so just
coming back to the the theme of this
talk which is the perspective played by
symbolic execution so even though in uh
test generation model checking
verification the symbolic execution is
being used essentially to guide the
search that is you try through symbolic
execution you play the role of many many
concrete executions whereas in debugging
repair
summarization program semantics
extraction somehow the symbolic
execution is playing the role of uh
uncovering what went wrong as well as
discovering the intended Behavior Uh all
of these are somehow exploiting uh all
of these techniques are built in such a
way that they're exploiting uh
similarities in large parts of the
search space in the case of debugging
for example among the deviations in the
case of repair trying to find out all
the test cases which need to be rescued
together and so on so I think there is a
fair amount of uh fair amount of space
to cover in this uh uh for these two
different roles of symbolic execution
one is the discovering of the intended
program Behavior and the other is the
guiding of the
search and uh of course just very
briefly let me mention one possible take
from today's discussion the symbolic
execution tries to infert the intended
Behavior we also did just one other work
where we directly try to uh capture the
intended Behavior through this uh change
contract specifications so there has
been fair amount of work on program
contracts uh where you try to give input
output specifications of programs so
here we try to look into change
contracts where you describe the
intended behavior of the changes so for
example the contract at the bottom is
saying that when these input conditions
are satis when these conditions are
satisfied and there are no input
conditions whenever the output the
previous output satisfies this condition
the new output should satisfy this
condition so uh these are really you can
give output output specifications
between the outputs of the two program
versions rather than input output
specifications which is more uh flexible
I
guess and uh let me just conclude by
giving you these references as well as
thanking uh all my uh co-authors and I
will be happy to take any more
questions summaries which is similar to
the change right right right yeah we
have discussed thing that I wanted to
say was I mean I guess you're giving too
much credit to symbolic execution if
you're looking at program verification
there's a much nicer inut to logic and
that sort of reduces the problem of path
explosion so you might be able to do a
lot of these things if you were to do PC
generation based uh encoding into logic
right that is true yeah actually a lot
of the techniques that we did were
Dynamic symbolic execution yeah that is
a symbolic execution over specific uh
Parts yeah
uh at least one of the initial
observations uh to me was that uh
specifically for reasoning about
regressions uh where you have a past
version of the program or for reasoning
about about cases like embedded software
where you have a reference
implementation of the program you can
use symbolic execution over this
reference implementation or the past
version to get some hint of the intended
behavior and for uh uh software
engineering activities like debugging if
you have a hint of the intended Behavior
it is a huge plus and this is really the
problem that we don't have formal
specifications in the program if I had
lots of formal specifications for each
of my methods then things like debugging
there really wouldn't be much to worry
about uh so symbolic execution uh
definitely was helpful in that regard in
the absence of these formal
specifications somehow to get a hint of
the formal
specification so in that uh that that is
one of the credits that I'm giving to
the symbolic
execution uh apart from the known usages
of symbolic EXE execution like uh
guiding search and so on but those
probably could be done by other methods
as well as you already
mentioned but the uh finding of the
intended Behavior probably I couldn't be
doing that through verification methods
because the verification methods require
a certain property to ver the program as
a property the previous version of a
program can be a property that could be
all I'm saying is that you can encode
any of these things into logic directly
sure sure that could that
could all
question okay thank
you